since 2006 Iran's gashed Earth Shad the
so-called morality police have in their
words spread a culture of modesty rights
activists say it's a culture of fear and
oppression new comments by the country's
attorney general that suggests this
Force could be abolished have been met
with skepticism and suggestions it's to
appease months of angry process in Iran
and overseas the morality police
functions under the authority of the
ministry of intelligence
everything that we had been seeing by
the current
Administration helmed by President raisi
indicated that he was in favor of more
strict mandatory hijab laws and policing
and in fact we saw an increase in the
number of morality police patrols since
the beginning of his administration so
whether or not the actual Authority
rests within the prosecutor General and
the judiciary's hands is yet to be seen
in September the morality police
arrested 22 year old Masha amini she had
allegedly broken the law by not wearing
a headscarf she died in custody
activists say more than 470 people have
now died in the protests that followed
and still continue mirrored by moments
on the international stage like when the
Iran football team didn't sing their
anthem at the World Cup
[Applause]
process across the world although the
Iranian government has now suggested it
could also review the 40 year old hijab
law there is no concrete evidence of a
softening position
this week anti-government activists said
a family home of el nazare Carby was
demolished in retaliation for the
climber not wearing a head covering at a
competition in South Korea
the hijab law review they believe is a
smoke screen to detract from demands
from protesters for a regime change and
reforms to rights which restrict women's
education political thought and freedom
of speech as Iranian women we are just
breathing
we think that we are living
because we are breathing but it is not
alive it is not a normal life so what
we've got to lose
and what we can gain so we think that
it's worth it
it is what our people are women are
sacrificing their lives for
fundamental women's and human rights
tsudabi believes these protests will not
stop that empty promises are not enough
that only regime change will bring true
reform
Catherine Sky News